thank you for coming to my session and I
start my session I see that I'm a
software engineer at cookpot I'm from
Japan but cookpot has research office so
I visited for business trip
currently I am working at machine
learning engineer but my background
includes a Pittsburgh episodic and I
like data engineers so and I'm a
contributor of Pittsburgh and tential
food and so on and I so my session is
about other than data engineering
machine learnings but my PI data London
session is very many machine banging so
I'm sorry if you don't okay I start and
at first I tried to introduce my company
doing a cook but it it can use in
England too it is a white flashes recipe
a sharing platform so and so please try
it to cooking good putt is scrubber
service and we have cristal office it is
second largest branch in my company
company there are about 250 people
working at the Bristol office and there
are about 10 researchers and engineers
about machine learning team and we are
working on an NLP Sibley and information
Little rivers about recipes it's a lot
of fun to cook in the kitchen of the
office during so work our work but is
used in 71 countries and to 2020
language we have 94 menuhin mastery of
race users the photo the photo right
right
it's a wrister office members we are
very friendly so I stopped I stopped and
my agenda is here so first of all I
expect at explaining but 5v lung power
and distributed processing and next I
explained the difference of power and
distributed processing and finally I
introduced some popular libraries for
power and processing is in person and
the architectures and features and this
is disclaimer I talked about basic
architecture and features of libraries
but I don't talk about the installation
and the detailed detailed up API usages
because we can easily get knowledge of
libraries usage from our internet
documents and any papers but it is
difficult to find a proper document
about abstract at Texas and how we use
how we choose rivalry and for that for
our cases yes yes and the first question
how do we decide whether to use parallel
distributed processing the answer is
mainly to many-to-one is that fairly
useless data feeds can cannot handle us
in one process or among machine the
resource which is available in one
process or one machine is limited but if
you we use more data than the limit
we have to use parallel or distributed
processing processing it will be able to
solve the problem problem of lack of
resource the second one is family-run
program in short time even if we can use
for us data in one machine if it occurs
that the job time is too wrong as in
such case parallel and distributed
processing will be very useful to so
short the job time so I said that last
take a large data but what is much data
in i i i drawn three patterns one is
from 1 million Bamian 100 million
megabytes and 10 gigabytes and one
terabyte it is the last data in fact it
is a case by case because the world
class is a related world if I take
example this current current technology
we use pandas dataframe from for machine
learning or a machine data engineering
but the pandas dataframe works
most efficiently with less than 1
gigabyte data with usual machines so but
[Music]
before parallel and distributed
processing
how about scared of scalp can solve lack
of resources too but
especially with criss-cross service
services it's very easy to expand a
machine resources in with the UI other
ways with disappea it is very easy so
easier than parallel processing or
distributed processing but there are
problem about problem in scarab - first
we sometimes we will be not able to use
full of machine resources with one
processes one process per meter one
person process we can use only one CPU
CPU as default so there may be many CPUs
and a lot of memories in machine this
was mainly sources but problem cannot is
efficiently the those resources and most
resource status is a weight second the
resource resources that can be
maintained on the one machine are
limited the high performance PC but it's
very expensive and very rare so when we
can't expand the resources more we
should consider scale out with
disabilities processing so let's learn
parallel processing and disputed
processing to process last data X
efficiently in fact parallel processing
and distributed processing is not same
so next question can you understands the
difference of power and distributed
processing can you answer can you know
okay okay also answer is here we open
this to if we are on use and these two
worlds same meaning but it's the not
same a parallel processing is mainly for
one only one machine and I the parallel
processing use multiple processor and
sharing the memory on the other hand
distributed processing a math
possibility of sharing sub processing by
exchanging data through messages between
multiple machines so we use resources
it's a physically separated yes and at
next I introduce as a library to the we
I introduced the library about parallel
processing and distributed processing
at first I introduced about parallel
processing libraries the first is
threating and mercy processing a person
has official modules for parallel
processing person is often said that a
battery included it means that person
itself can use various functions wizard
third-party libraries so we can use
parallel parallel processing wizard
third-party libraries as threating I
explained I explained about
threating here is the image of persons
sweating objection here we learn Python
programs the problem has one main thread
as a process where we use fretting
libraries we can use some substrates for
parallel processing the thread number is
parallel number so in this image the
program creates two substrates for
parallel processing but in reading there
is a limit for GL environment only one
thread can use CPU at the same time even
even if the program has two or three or
more threads so Python threading is in
fact not power but it's concurrent from
aspects of CPU execution but ygi is used
C Python interpreter does not implement
some mechanisms of synchronization for
the concurrent access by threads so
there isn't GL in Jason and item person
or another another distribution or
person and currently pp5 5ho proposes a
sub interpreted the obscurity earth
about I think about in pattern 3.8 I
think but in what situation in rating
effective so setting cannot use CPU in
power but we can use oil processing
during another sweating are using CPU so
this is IO process processes so it's
effective for a low bond programs such
as which write files what they be
connections or download data from
networks CPUs uses cannot duplicate but
I will process some duplicates between 2
or 3 threads but if use if we use too
many threads there of course many
context switch which decrease decrease
performance so we should be careful to
increase the number of threads next much
processing much processing spawns
process for prior parallelization and
reprocessing devilry parallelized
in both local and remote machines let's
study more about how much processing
device one process the sub process
process this much processing library
each process has its own memory use
space spaces it's different from
threating features a memory in express
threading so it's not effective I've
affected by gar and less likely
technique to cause our jury
due to rest condition data corruption or
the trap
and what situation is multiple
processing effective because of such a
feature must process is much processing
is effective at tasks it is CPU bands
such as numerical calculation much
matrix manipulation or regular
expression processing as a performance
impotence much processing doesn't
increase linearly linearly because their
overheads but its overhead also the
suburb always function to a submerged
processing but peasants mercy processing
Level II used always fog function always
folks function copies and necessary
resources such as memory spaces from
parent process to child process and so
for example
memory size of parent process is very
lost
there is overhead due to communication
between parent process and charge
processes at children processes and one
more overhead then another point of
point to take care text which can land
at same time is limited to the number of
CPU attached on the machine so fare will
learn six tasks the on the machine which
has only two CPUs to two tasks run at
first and after finish those tasks and
another task will start if you'd like to
increase the number of related ISM you
have to increase CPU number of machines
next I introduce about Joe bleep Joe
Phil Chinese fretting and master eating
much processing level its function more
simply and functionary job leaves the
default but and is lucky but it is the
third party parallel at Texas but we can
use threatening and much processing very
easily to and Lucky's our goal is me is
very similar to material processing tale
and Java has lady a variation function
and he can use transparent discussing of
the output output calculations performed
as needed by the outputs and only thing
its inputs chance double obtained rhythm
very simply and easily than threating
and much processing it is truly
recommended for uses of three threating
or and much processing last feature is
that logging logging we can logging and
tracing we can use logging and tracing
of the execution with job tape so we can
debug my our processes of easily in this
top lib somebody up to here but i has
officer modules who are parallel
processing setting is effective the i/o
bound processing and multi processing is
effective the cpu ban processing both of
or mainly for only four processes run at
one only one thing we can use fitting
and much processing functions is jumping
more simply and some of the libraries
transparently use this parallel
processing libraries for example
it's much sweated using brass or see in
implementation when we learn tensile
role with CPU tensile flow is most
processed using buckland implementation
and such climb is depends on job flip so
we in fact use parallel processing and
constants consciously the next is this
rigid processing we finally got the
distributed processing it was very long
from the session started
please remember distributed processing
architecture when we have to use
distributed processing when we have to
use distributed processing we have to
consider about this video distributed
processing when we used last data fit
couldn't process in one machine and we
introduced by introduced three libraries
a wine steadily vines tasks and the
final finally high spark parody parody
is the dispute task queue built in
Python Python and series feature is here
simple and sorry has simple and frisk
flexible at textures and every path can
be extended heavy we can heavy used for
task based work Road is in pattern for
example jungle back end or arrow back
end calories architecture is here so we
have several components local belong
it's cast and store that store the
result results into the path
results store so when we learn a job at
client the application will be sent to
broker and broker has several kills so
the application will be sent to one of
the Q so Q will send the application and
paralyzed and sent the sensor
applications tasks to several workers
workers will run tasks and unsaved the
result button patent stories in past
situations is salary effective friends
the task in three is effective when the
task is simple but the amount of data is
too much for one machine then you want
to use its with another frameworks such
as jungle since early is very simple
task queue system simple task but a
month data is picky for one machine will
search for it but when you track the
land complex tasks on Saturday you have
to write a lot of course so it is not so
good recommended next is task dusk dust
is distributed processing framework bit
in Python a pure Python library the able
T test is able to use sample pandas
restrike parallel objects it it it is
named as dusk la dusk data frame and
dust back schedule has
on schedule schedule is customizable to
get good performance from boss for
parallel processing and distributed
processing and on crustal task has good
web interface for real real time job
monitoring this is task scheduler that's
the dust application online
the object is array but and data frame
we reuse this object for for our court
and the task will generate task graph to
run the parallel processing schedule
we'll use synchronous and thread and
much processing or disputed that
interface is very beautiful so we can
debug tuning tuning the our programs
with easily easily with this you
whirring but in fact situation is does
good effective desk is effective when we
want to parallel life vampire or pandas
processing friends the data size fits
that that is effective when the data
size fits one for one to four or five
machines finally I introduce pass back
first part is bid in bid in Java and has
pattern interface i passport can be made
more scale out scan Austin steadily or
dusk passport is originally built to run
on Hadoop cluster
pestpac has a very many implementation
but the performance tuning so the
passport is fastest and most cost
efficient in very huge data so and
passed park also has good web interface
interface and such as same as dusk and
pass but can be eased a life complex
program it's these operators Facebook
has a stream API and my machine learning
API so we can implement very many type
of calls we can use we can use pass back
with management management service in
cloud service such as other ways or at
the rest
EMR or disappea it is passed park
architecture spot is built-in with with
Java but we can use pattern of operator
when we use Python operated as a person
called the data will be tickled pickles
and pathology will transfer the data to
the sparks dead sparks data architecture
architecture and sent to Walker
it is a scale of salary and desks and
dusk
anti-spark we can use Saturday and dusk
for one machine to four or five machine
but passport can be used in one mm no
nose so a spark can use very very few
data but that's sir II can't use so huge
data so in fact situation is passport
effective when we want to run fast buck
is effective when we want to learn
complex tasks with a large amount of
data very high and if we use Hadoop
cluster passport is recommended overhead
operate disputed processing I introduced
distributed processing but in
distributed processing is not sold it's
not and super breath so we we have
overhead so if we use small data
distributed processing is not
recommended it's under straw it's time
completion we can use machine machine
resources efficiently and speeds of our
program with parallel disputed
processing the several parallel
processing libraries available in
pattern
I recommend Joffrey for general uses
opera federalism in one machine that's I
recommend task for pair already
prioritized pandas dataframe program I
recommend price park for few state which
cannot handle in one machine
don't afraid to use power or distributed
processing ban thank you very much
[Applause]
I'm sorry
you mean MPA MP is row rebel API
implemented in c and and MPA is MPA
means a to to MPI has two means one is a
protocol for message passing and the
second is a library name the library is
open MPA or another MPI libraries they
mainly implemented in c and very
low-level implemented so disputed where
we learn distributed processing the
framework should should have a partition
tolerance functions or the backup and
recovery system and we try system but
native MPI system library did not have
such functions but MPI is very fast so
we can't compare pythons passport or
desks desks to MPI it is it has good
points and bad points okay
at the beginning yes always sorry as
threating and I introduced threatening
and multi-processing
and threating is for our bond process
processes and multi-processing library
is for a CPU bond process processes
because because the threating cannot use
as CP CP you duplicate duplicate we
could I answer you know thank you
[Applause]